hey this is presh talwalkar and you're
watching mind your decisions
here's a fun problem given to elementary
school students in china
how tall is the table based on the
following
pictures i adapted this problem from a
tweet by china focus
can you figure it out
give this problem a try and when you're
ready keep watching the video for a
solution
[Music]
so one way to solve this problem is to
use algebra
the first picture we can translate into
the following equation
we have the height of the cat plus the
height of the table minus the height of
the turtle is equal to 170.
the second picture will correspond to
the equation the height of the turtle
plus the height of the table minus the
height of the cat is equal to 130
so now from these two equations we need
to solve for the height of the table
there's a neat little trick we can do
we can add these two equations together
the variables of cat and turtle will
then cancel out
so we have two times table is equal to
170 plus 130 which is 300 and therefore
table is equal to 150
so the height of the table is 150
centimeters
that's one way we could solve the
problem
now there's also a clever way if you
think visually
imagine stacking these two pictures on
top of each other
now notice the height from the top of
the cat at the bottom to the top of the
cat at the top is equal to 130 plus 170
which is 300
we can then erase the animals from the
picture
and then we can rearrange it and we can
clearly see that the height of two
tables is 300 so the height of one table
will be 150 centimeters
did you figure it out
thanks for watching this video
these map videos which can be watched
for free on youtube inspire and build
confidence for people around the world
and they already have over 100 million
views let's share the beauty of
mathematics with your help we can math
the world a better place
please subscribe for free to get the
newest videos
watch and share all of mine your
decisions videos
email me a puzzle or math topic presh
mindyourdecisions.com
if you so choose you can check out my
books which are listed in the video
description and you can support me on
patreon for exclusive rewards
thanks for watching and thanks for your
support